l'enfer c'est en ce terme que le
président michel aoun qualifie la
situation libanaise actuelle si un
nouveau gouvernement ne se forme pas
dans les plus brefs délais nous n'avons
plus le luxe du temps
vous avez dit que vous aviez proposé
beaucoup de choses mais n'ont pas été
approuvées c'est cette information du
gouvernement n'ait pas approuvé
où allons-nous en enfer bien sûr le
liban ne supporte pas les coups d'état
ou les chocs
il a été construit sur la démocratie et
sur l' équilibre entre les composantes
de la société
c'est notre fondement une semaine après
la date butoir fixée par emmanuel macron
les querelles partisanes autour du
portefeuille des finances entravent la
formation du nouveau gouvernement dirigé
par mustapha hadid six rendez-vous de
fin octobre
ce sur quoi vos dirigeants se sont
engagés n'est pas au rendez vous nous
devons en tirer les conséquences alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
soit rien n'a été fait et ce moment là
c'est clair je devrais dire à la
communauté internationale
nous ne pouvons pas être au rendez-vous
de l'aide au liban mais je devrai aussi
vous expliquer expliquer aux libanaises
aux libanais nous étions prêts à vous
aider vos dirigeants en ont décidé
autrement
le liban vit depuis un an l'une des
pires crises économiques sociales et
politiques de son histoire une crise
amplifié par la pandémie de comics 19 et
l'explosion tragique le 4 août au port
de beyrouth qui a fait des centaines de
victimes et des dizaines de milliers de
sans abri
la communauté internationale dont la
france exige du liban des réformes
structurelles en contrepartie d'un
soutien international de plusieurs
milliards d'euros